Привіт, любі п’ятикласники!
Я традиційно розпочала свій урок
із вітання,
у якому вжила звертання –
любі п’ятикласники!
Сьогодні ми більш докладно поговоримо
про розділові знаки при звертанні.
Пригадаємо!
На минулому уроці ми говорили
про види звертань.
Поговорімо про розділові знаки.
Зверніть увагу на схеми!
Звертання у середині речення, відповідно,
з обох боків стоять коми.
Звертання на початку речення,
і вимовлене з окличною інтонацією.
Тому після звертання – знак оклику,
а наступне речення – з великої літери.
Звертання на початку речення – ставимо
кому після нього, тобто, після звертання.
Якщо звертання в кінці речення,
то перед звертанням ставимо кому.
В кінці може бути крапка або знак оклику,
залежно від інтонації.
Ми бачимо це на схемах:
або знак оклику, або крапка,
але обов’язково – кома перед звертанням.
У цьому реченні ми вжили займенник ти,
але він не є звертанням
і ніколи ти, ви не бувають звертаннями.
Тому ми їх, ні в якому разі,
не відокремлюємо комами.
У цьому речення звертанням буде: друзі,
яке стоїть на початку речення.
Відповідно, відокремлюємо його комою
з одного боку.
Хочу звернути вашу увагу на книгу
Івана Андрусяка «Зайчикова книжечка».
Розгорнімо й прочитаймо анотацію!
Ми ж з вами разом
із Зайчиком та зайченятами
з цієї книги будемо вивчати звертання.
Починається книга з таких слів.
Мій Зайчику – звертання.
Поширене чи непоширене?
Поширене, адже складається з двох слів.
Оскільки воно на початку речення,
то після звертання ставимо кому.
Зверніть увагу, що в цьому реченні також є
однорідні члени речення,
які ми вивчали на попередніх уроках:
пухнаста, вухата, куцохвоста, смішна,
а ще: до тебе, до мами, до тата.
Нумо практикувати.
Звертання – зайчиську.
Оскільки ми його вимовляємо з
окличною інтонацією,
то, відповідно, знак оклику в кінці.
Звертання: зайчиську
в середині речення.
З обох боків стоять коми.
Мій Зайчику – звертання,
яке стоїть в кінці речення.
Перед звертанням поставили кому
і в кінці – знак оклику,
оскільки речення за емоційним забарвленням
є окличним.
Які ж види цих звертань?
Зайчиську і зайчиську – непоширені
звертання;
мій Зайчику – поширене звертання.
Нагадую вам, що звертання ми вживаємо
лише в кличному відмінку!
Наступне завдання.
Будьте уважними!
Спробуйте спочатку самостійно.
Звертання їжаче стоїть наприкінці речення
Отже, перед ним має бути кома.
У ругому реченні звертання – Лисе.
Погляньмо, де воно стоїть – в середині
речення.
Тому перед Лисе кома
і після Лисе теж кома.
В останньому реченні друже
– кома перед звертанням
і після звертання також ставимо кому.
Які ж види цих звертань?
Їжаче, лисе, друже – це непоширені
звертання.
Нумо далі практикувати.
Перше речення.
Звертання – гульвісо.
Кома перед звертанням і після звертання.
Воно є непоширеним.
Друге речення.
Зверніть увагу на звертання
в цьому реченні.
Не лише одне слово Зайчику,
а й залежні від нього слова:
мій брате Зайчику.
Мій брате Зайчику – ось звертання
в цьому реченні.
Перед мій ставимо кому,
тобто, перед початком звертання,
і наприкінці звертання теж кома.
Це звертання є поширеним і складається
з трьох слів.
Третє речення.
У цьому реченні звертання: любий братику.
Перед словом любий ставимо кому.
Це звертання є поширеним.
Четверте речення.
Звертання – брате.
З обох боків виділяємо комами.
Непоширене звертання.
П'яте речення.
Звертання – братику.
Перед ним та після нього ставимо коми.
Це звертання є непоширеним.
Шосте речення.
Звертання – друзі.
Перед ним і після нього ставимо коми,
непоширене.
Сьоме речення.
Звертання – пане Коте.
З обох боків ставимо коми.
Звертання стоїть у середині речення,
і воно є поширеним.
Нумо практикувати далі.
Наше завдання - поставити звертання
в кличному відмінку, розкривши дужки.
Спробуйте спочатку самостійно.
Перевіримо.
Ви звернули увагу, що звертаннями будуть:
Зайчику – непоширене,
Зайчику мій – поширене,
Зайчику і маля – непоширені звертання.
Обов’язково їх виділяємо комами.
А ви знаєте, що існує чимало приказок
про зайців?
Найпоширенішими з них є такі...
За двома зайцями поженешся –
жодного не впіймаєш.
Видно зайця по вухах.
Зайця ноги носять, вовка зуби годують.
Полохливому зайцю і пеньок - вовк.
Більш докладно поговорімо про
першу приказку:
«За двома зайцями поженешся –
жодного не впіймаєш».
Значення є таким.
Справді, якщо погнатися за одним зайцем
і за другим зайцем,
то, зрештою, обидва зайці втечуть
і жодного не спіймаєш.
Так і в житті із справами:
коли починаєш виконувати і одну справу,
і другу справу одночасно, і, зрештою,
не маєш результатів ні з тієї, ні з іншої.
Існують різні варіанти
цієї приказки (на екрані).
Дуже багато фразеологізмів про зайців.
Нагадаю вам, що фразеологізм – це стійке
словосполучення.
Увага на екран!
Нумо грати і конструювати!
Ваше завдання:
складіть речення з наведених слів.
Спробуйте поставити звертання на початку,
у середині та в кінці речення.
Якщо надписати ці слова на кубиках леґо,
то можна скласти ось такі речення:
Перше речення сформулюємо зі звертанням
на початку.
Звертання в нашому реченні – друзі.
Отож, шукаємо, кубик із надписом: «друзі».
Друзі – звертання на початку
після звертання має бути обов’язково
розділовий знак,
скажімо, кома.
Ставимо кому.
Друзі, вивчаймо українську мову.
Перше речення може бути таким.
Далі ми по-іншому складемо наш кубик.
Наступне речення – звертання у середині.
Вивчаймо, а далі – звертання.
Пам’ятаємо, що перед звертанням
має стояти кома.
Шукаємо кому.
Звертання друзі – шукаємо, друзі, є.
Після звертання обов’язково має бути кома…
Ще одна кома.
Продовження речення:
Вивчаймо, друзі, українську...
мову.
У середині речення звертання,
з обох боків ми його відокремили комами.
Останнє речення буде зі звертанням
наприкінці.
Починаємо!
Нам потрібне слово вивчаймо,
далі – українську,
мову і друзі.
Пам’ятаємо, що якщо
звертання наприкінці речення,
то перед ним має обов’язково стояти кома.
В кінці речення може
бути знак оклику, крапка,
а може і знак питання – залежно від
вашої інтонації.
В таку гру ви можете пограти вдома
зі своїми рідними, друзями.
Можете будь-які слова наклеїти
на кубики леґо
і погратися таким чином.
Сподіваюся, що ви засвоїли тему:
«Звертання».
Тож, нумо виконувати тести.
Прошу вас на аркуші паперу або ж у зошиті
записати від 1 до 6.
Завдання будуть тестовими.
Тож, біля цифри треба вписати лише літеру
з правильною відповіддю.
Розпочнімо!
Друге питання:
Третє питання:
Четверте питання:
П'яте питання:
Шосте питання:
Час перевіряти.
Якщо ви правильно виконали всі тестові
завдання, то мають бути такі відповіді.
Незабаром пролунає дзвінок,
тож час записувати домашнє завдання.
Дякую за увагу!
До нових уроків!